we're expecting around 80 folks it's  going to be outside of the  courthouse so definitely excited for  that latinx  folks are going to be the biggest voting  block in this election and we want to  make sure that that stays true  even through the pandemic latinos have  the decision in nevada  just making sure that you know they feel  empowered that voting is the right  choice to make that they should feel  empowered and they should exercise that  right as well  i really encourage our community to get  out and vote and to do that  from the comfort of your home you can  fill out your ballot and then you can  either drop it off at a drop-off  location or you can just send it in the  mail  our vote is going to win even more than  it has before  but it's not going to do that if we  don't cast our ballots  so what we need to do is make sure that  every latino vote  gets counted our voices strong in this  community  and our voice is stronger when we vote